il y a les les les ronds bleus et gris
allez-y tirez-le découvrir les bases du
smartphone le thème de l'atelier
dispensé ce jour-là dans le digitrock à
une dizaine de participants jusqu'au 9
septembre prochain un camion bien
particulier fait étape devant la gare de
Noisy-le-Roi reconverti en salle de
classe connectée celui propose des cours
gratuits pour mieux comprendre les
équipements digitaux un univers parfois
obscur pour ce public senior les
questions les plus classiques c'est par
exemple pourquoi j'ai ça à quoi ça me
sert sur mon téléphone voilà bon bah
comment ça marche le bluetooth le mode
avion il sert à quoi est-ce que ça veut
dire
QR code Reader
QR code lecteur
Girard 82 ans n'avait jamais eu de
formation sur les nouvelles technologies
il se réjou de recevoir des cours
structurées pour mieux intégrer des
informations parfois complexes j'avais
d'énormes lacunes sur le numérique il y
avait beaucoup de fonctions du
smartphone qui est un bijou de
technicité beaucoup de
particularité du smartphone que
j'ignorais totalement donc j'ai appris
il m'en reste encore beaucoup beaucoup à
apprendre mieux appréhender
l'utilisation d'un ordinateur protéger
ses données ou aider à la recherche
d'emploi en ligne le public est invité à
découvrir les fondamentaux quel que soit
son âge la fracture numérique peut
concerner toutes les générations les
jeunes ils ont super doué en fait à
utiliser le smartphone etc mais par
contre dans ce qui est de basique
comment configurer qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire attention la sécurité etc et là
ils ont besoin vraiment venir et
travailler de son personne sont
attendues sur ces 15 jours de présence à
Noisy-le-Roi organisé depuis 2021 le
digitrock a accueilli 4500 apprenants
dans toute la France il poursuivra son
itinéraire numérique aux Essarts-le-Roi
dès le 11 septembre